today's question comes from nema in
maryland my husband and i have no debt
we have a significant savings account
considering our income and my husband is
super responsible with the budget
the problem is that i can't stand to
budget i hate the accountability
the time it takes and how confusing it
is
besides for just sucking it up and
telling myself to be a big girl
what can i do to shift my mindset
and my actions this is interesting to me
because i'm curious
i feel like there's more there of why
don't you like it because it really
shouldn't be that confusing especially
if you have no debt and you are
using something simple like every dollar
where it's actually fun to drag and drop
your expenses and their categories and
um
you know i don't know i don't know if
you don't if you don't know why
something matters you don't want to do
it but if you could see the payoff of
how you actually
control your money versus it controlling
you then the means to the end becomes
worth it i don't know what do you think
dave what
what else is she saying in that question
um
but i'm not sure uh that there's
obviously a lot of possibilities
number one um yeah you need to know why
you're doing it
because otherwise just it's not
confusing it's really not that hard and
it doesn't take that much time
once you start doing it so it really
does come down to
the accountability and uh
you know so if you're self-admitting i'm
a princess and i don't want to be told
no
even by my own self for my own good
then you might as well eat a box of
donuts at every meal
and be 800 pounds i mean if you have no
self-control whatsoever yeah and no
accountability to
for your own benefit yeah i mean you
know it's just
it's just misbehavior it's just
immaturity at that point but i don't
think that's really what it is here
um i'm kind of thinking
that that you know i'm a spender and i
learned
to love the budget because it gives me
permission
to spend that's what i'm saying i wonder
if what she's saying without saying it
is her and her husband
don't see the budget the same so like
for her she doesn't feel the freedom to
put in the budget what she wants to
spend money and feels that we have money
to spend on i don't think she's got a
voice in this yeah but she hasn't
bothered to take it either she's
copping out yeah you know i just need to
be a big girl there's a little whining
going on yeah
so uh you know yeah you do need to be a
big girl and you need to speak up and
say
okay we've got plenty of room in this
budget we make plenty of money we don't
have any debt
and we're going to put some joy on the
paper here
you set the budget you can make it look
like whatever you want it to be for
money
yeah it's your money but you're not in
congress you can't just spend
not infinite you just can't keep going
and going and going and going and going
that doesn't work
so yeah you do have to have some
boundaries but they
that but they're your boundaries you get
to set them so a i think she's probably
not speaking into it doesn't feel like
she's got control
b probably nerd husband's got the budget
too tight yes
to where there's no joy in this thing um
and then c yeah you do have to be a big
girl and suck it up yeah
uh there's part of that in there too no
whining allowed but it might be that you
just need to
take control of this it is a spending
plan
yeah it's how you're going to spend your
money yeah so it's not saying
you know dave ramsey doesn't want me to
ever have fun again oh shut up
the whole point of living like no one
else is later you can live and give like
no one else the whole point of
paying a price to win is and oh by the
way it's your choice dave ramsey's not
coming to your house
right and straighten you out right every
night when you misbehave
i mean this is a matter of are you going
to be a grown up and are you going to
control your destiny
that's all it is it's not me telling you
and and i don't think that
you need to live on beans and rice the
rest of your life and i don't hate poor
people
i have been both um and it's easier when
you have a little money so i'm trying to
teach you how to have a little money
it's that simple
uh so you know the whining
lefties are just beyond belief but
they're there and so she's not that her
thing is she just
isn't speaking into this and she doesn't
feel power yeah and i feel like she's
gaining power over her life
and this thing is being used by her
husband to control her
yeah yeah and she points out we have no
debt we have significant savings
considering our income
and my husband is super responsible the
budgets there's all the backstory why
she can't use that
i can't stand to budget you need to
answer the question why can't you stand
a budget
and she says i don't like it's confusing
it takes time that's bull
it's absolute bull yeah she's not
represented in the budget you're not
represented you don't have
any say you don't feel like you have any
say maybe he's not
being hardcore but you're just
anticipating that he is right
maybe that's the way you were raised i
don't know what's going on here but
but there's there's something about you
need a voice in this you need to set it
you've got some room you need to put
some fun some joy on the paper
enjoy your money some of it but then yes
you need to have
guardrails we all you never make enough
money to not have guardrails yeah
i mean i make a lot of money and i have
guardrails yeah you know i have
boundaries you have a plan
they're different boundaries than when i
was broke yeah but there's still
boundaries there's still guard rails you
know you got different different
situations